cebellum
solution is is going to be or in our
vision is the go-to product or the go-to
platform for for product security teams
where they actually manage the risk and
the security of all their products
throughout the entire life cycle from
design through development to
post-production
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this episode is with slava bronfman the
ceo of cebellum
slava is an experienced cyber security
leader and entrepreneur as the ceo of
cebellum he is responsible for the
business sales and marketing operations
working with manufacturers and asset
owners worldwide on implementing risk
assessment solutions as part of founding
cyberum's development of a novel product
security technology slava is the
official representative of the standards
institution of israel in the iso 21434
standard technical committee leading iso
21434 use case tf
he is also a member of the sisa software
component transparency committee working
on the future standardization of
software bom
he holds an msc in computer science
laude and a bachelor's of science and
information systems from laude
i'm so excited to hear why you do what
you do and you know running cybelum such
a cool company looking at the life cycle
of connected devices end-to-end securing
them
in a such a weird world that we're
living today where
we have such a complex chain of the life
cycle of the end-to-end of these
connected devices and i'm excited to
understand from you a little bit about
uh you know what are the different
opportunities that are there why and and
most importantly why it's so exciting
for you
so slava to tell me a little bit about
yourself and how did you get into the
cyberspace the connected devices space
and why you love it so much
great so um great question michael so um
i'll start by saying you know on
personal level i like to to build things
uh to build things you know especially
when the there is a big challenge and
there is um really a big problem that
involves you know in the interaction of
uh technological problem together with
some business problem and the
interaction of the two is really where
i'm getting excited and i think that's
it's something that we are solving today
in cebellum
um so as i said seven we are in the
product security world which is um you
know different from i.t security or ot
security uh because we are dealing with
uh mostly with you know when when you
say product security it's really not
about iot or small devices it's more
about
you know big safety critical systems um
you know like connected vehicles and
medical devices
um you know industrial iot stuff like
that
and um i got to this field you know or
in the cyber uh field in general from
like i guess most of the
cyber interpreters in israel from the
israeli military right from the israeli
army served in the um
in the intelligence corps and we're
dealing a lot with connected devices uh
from different angles of that uh issue
and when we started cyber we basically
you know we
we were looking for a big problem to
solve and one of our uh let's say
advisors he used to run the product
security team in daimler dino mercedes
today is already mercedes-benz it used
to be daimler and he basically you know
presented us the challenges that he had
as the you know the head of the all the
product security meaning uh leading all
the vehicles security of mercedes
and um you know believe it or not it was
really funny for me then to to see that
there is no regulation whatsoever and
right if you look at all the i.t
security there are tons of um you know
cyber security practices and and
regulation and standards and so on and
when it came to um
physical you know to real uh safety
critical uh systems like vehicles there
was practically nothing there and the
other very interesting challenge is that
this entire industry like automotive and
others are completely built on a very
complex supply chain
meaning eventually right the
manufacturer who we call the
manufacturer like you know mercedes ford
mazda you name it uh they're basically
the biggest integrators in the world
meaning they're taking all the
components from their tiered one uh
suppliers who then receive you know
components from their tier twos and so
on and eventually they are integrating
all these black boxes together
and traditionally they you know they
were okay because it was only about um
safety so you don't need to see inside
those black box components to understand
you know the the safety level of them
you can just you know do some crash
tests and stuff like that to understand
if the the component or the system is
safe or not
but when it comes to cyber security um
you know it is challenging to protect
the system even if you have a full
visibility inside if you if you are
developing gate and have all the source
code and so on so just think how
complicated and complex it is when uh
you just get the completely black box
component and eventually the liability
uh for the security of that is yours
so um you know to me it was absolutely
fascinating to understand you know to
see both the challenges
um and how complex it is and that there
is no solution and you know the business
part of that was that i understood that
this is an emerging market a huge market
uh with very few players that are um you
know playing there and even the ones
that are playing they're trying to take
traditional i.t
uh solutions and apply it to to the
product security world and we basically
thought differently and that's basically
how we kick started cyber
can you tell me a little bit about sort
of the the early days of when you
started this a little bit about you know
you're mentioning coming out of the
military and the intelligence and and it
sounds like you have a different point
of view on on the complexity of these
connected devices and and and the way
that you're you're going to solve this
problem i'd love to hear just a little
bit about you know your own strategy and
thinking process first-time entrepreneur
coming out
you know starting this thing and saying
no i i have this great vision i i have
this problem that i that i truly love
and a space that i love but but still
there's a gap between creating a company
from it today post series a and
from an initial excitement so how did
you fill that gap for you
oh
yeah you know it was actually a huge gap
that i think i'm still feeling it slowly
mainly by uh consulting with many other
people you know many other folks that
did it um you know greatly um
a couple of times before
and that's basically my strategy of for
my philosophy of approaching things i
know that
i i just really try to identify what i
don't know
and that's you know one of the hardest
things to do but uh one once you
pinpoint what you exactly don't know
then you can basically i wouldn't say
delegate but kind of you know present
this uh problem to someone that's you
know um been there done that kind of
um
and that's
i think that's what i'm i'm doing for
the last five or six years i was lucky
enough you know to
to have around me um really a bunch of
uh strategic advisors that i'm used for
various topics so as i said um you know
i identified i think the problem also
you know using some one of our
board advisors that actually is still
working with us today the guy that i
mentioned before who is to to run the
product security for dandler
and um
yeah so i think you know the the main
thing that i was trying to do throughout
all this uh
period is to ask the right question and
then to consult with many other people
and as you said there is a big gap from
you know identifying an issue and be
kind of excited about it and really i
really believe in getting in love with
the problem and that's what i think what
um i really had you know early on when
we started cybele
but moving forward you know to to to
forming the go-to-market strategy um
and um you know building the sales team
doing the first initial sales um
everything about it hr and so on i was
really consulting um on almost on a
daily basis with other people and i
think that's
that that's really you know for me it's
one of the
secret uh you know to success
i i love that and obviously there's so
much more added complexity and from
stemming from this philosophy of
humbleness and and of creating the sort
of personal advisory board of people
that you trust that you understand to
keep to keep those checks and balances
and still you know being in love with
you know with this problem space tell me
a little bit about the the vision for
isabellum and you know i'm translating
your passion for this research and for
the space to product to the
productization of it and how you see
cybelum interact with with the complex
world around us well how does that
happen for you
yeah so something that we identified at
the beginning or actually when we
started it was just in a very few
companies we identified there is a new
role
the role was
we call sipso chief product security
officer which in a sense is a peer of
the cso that we all know from the
security space the chief information
security officer you know these guys
that all the cyber security companies
are complaining that they are very hard
to sell to right
um and uh so we start you know we call
it the
the beginning when we started cyber we
called it the rise of the sip so
uh because we understood that for you
know for these uh huge companies that
manufacturing cars and so on they have
their biggest asset is obviously their
products right and they invest so much
on i.t security um and we understood
that
there is no chance that in you know in a
couple of years uh the role of the cis
of the sip saw and the budget that the
you know that the entire product
security team will will get uh wouldn't
be at least equivalent to the you know
to the i.t security of those companies
um and we you know kind of identified
this trend of the product security or
the racing of product security and uh we
really tried you know to build a
solution around that practice and again
when we started product security wasn't
even a term i think and there is for
sure no you know practices of how to run
it what are you know the proper
way to to you know a proper way to to
conduct product security assessments or
you know manage vulnerabilities for
products
and so on so we really identified the
product security team and head of it the
chief product security officer as our
champions and tried to build a solution
that will uh focus on this uh people
that um and again that our thesis back
then was that um it's a growing practice
and it's gonna be a huge market as we
actually witnessing uh today what
the product security actually became
and um our vision is actually to
continue with that growth so and
continue to support the product security
team so um
in our vision product security is going
to be a practice uh by itself um really
similar to i.t security and to ot
security and so on and um similarly like
you know like cso have all the tools to
manage the security of of all the
enterprise or even you know from another
world like sales people have the sales
force uh to manage all their operations
so cebellum um solution is is gonna be
or in our vision is the go-to
product or the go-to platform for for
product security teams where they
actually manage the risk and the
security of all their products
throughout the entire life cycle from
design through development to
post-production uh and so on so that's
basically where we're heading and um
yeah
now we're talking about a vision that
you're mentioning is
basically you're continuing on a vision
that was set forth about five six years
ago when you when you first started out
now today in hindsight it's very easy to
come and say yeah look we have an
amazing market that is growing and
everybody agrees that product security
is is an incredible market
what what what led you to that belief
five or six years ago how did you how
did you get that conviction where you
were able to come up with this thesis
and and say this is what i believe in
and and we're going to build a company
that will act on it and obviously you
were right
yeah so it was you know a combination of
multiple things um one as i said before
the first thing was that we saw a new
role in the company a senior role that
was reporting to the board
uh or directly to the ceo and you know
once you have someone that is very
senior
probably or our assumption was that
budgets and a full team and you know
responsibility will follow
the other thing was you know the great
connectivity
that uh is actually was starting or was
just you know picking up uh we all know
you know we already talked for many
years or about connected cars and
connected medical devices and connected
you know smart meters in the energy
field and so on but we understood that
there is no um you know there is no
certain chance that in a couple of years
there won't be any regulation and
compliance for this you know basically
um
create safety critical systems so we're
really um bet on it that you know there
will be uh regulation and compliance and
budgets of course will follow and the
need for you know tool solution will
come with that as well
um
and i think that above all it was uh you
know um
a bit of belief that uh
that everything in uh you know
everything that is connected needs
security and eventually it will come
there so we see every niche market in
the iit security eventually becomes kind
of you know
a real market so
you know this belief that it will come
to
those products uh was for us kind of
obvious and that's we followed that
fascinating now as a leader what is it
what is the success for you here so you
you you know you love the place you're
building a great company how when will
you
sort of declare success on your own your
own mission as lava well what does
lava's success look like
um yeah so um
it's a tricky question um
maybe you know that about six months ago
or seven months ago we actually um sold
most of the company to lg to lg
electronics uh which is uh you know not
many now but they are one of the
big largest you know tier ones for
automotive in the world
um
and for us it was actually you know it
wasn't the end but just another
milestone uh because uh we actually
remained a fully independent company uh
independent brand with our you know just
we have
change of uh board members um
so and and the reason that we decided to
leave the company independent and not
just be part of lg or just some
development center or you know something
like that for lg is that we understand
that this field um you know is just kind
of scratching the surface we're just in
the early very early days of product
security
so a success for me would be that cebu
will be really the de facto um you know
uh
platform or the go-to platform for
product security teams around the world
where they are really managing you know
the security of all their products so um
you know it's really hard to put
really
very kind of
a very clear milestone when i will say
okay this is success but
um but seeing more and more you know
companies in more verticals like today
we're focused mostly on automotive
medical and a bit of energy so going to
other verticals like telecom and
aviation and so on and expanding the the
solution and seeing that cebulum will
remain kind of a sustainable company uh
in all these areas for me will be um
would be a success
it definitely feels that it's this is
not necessarily stem just from financial
reasons and from from that type of
success but it stems from a real
curiosity about this field you truly
believe that this is an emerging an
emerging space that has big implications
and organizations in in whatever they do
and this is a growing a growing market
that that is now appearing in every
domain of our life and so it definitely
seems that that that while you know the
the acquisition of the majority of the
company by lg is is a phenomenal
milestone it sounds like you're treating
it as a milestone in a more complex
journey that you're on which is being it
being a leader in the in the product
security space and and and i think that
that stems from you know both from the
the uh the conversation that we're
having here the way that i hear you
speak about your work and why you're
doing it but also from the way that
you're presented outside and and
that's pretty inspiring that's really
cool meeting people that are you know
that are truly curious about what they
do and they're really excited about what
they're doing to the point where they're
saying yeah you know a financial
milestone is another milestone but
that's not the end goal and so i really
appreciate that thank you
no sure absolutely i am you know i'm a
true believer obviously i'm biased but
i'm
i'm all in in that uh in that theory i'm
true believers i get inspired by
i get inspired by true believers and i
really want to thank you for taking the
time i know you're very busy and for
coming here and speaking with me and
sharing with me a little bit about why
the wife for you and why you do what you
do
with cybele and congratulations again on
all the amazing achievements and i look
forward to continuing to see what will
happen with cybelum and and with your
own work so thank you very very much
slava and stay safe and stay healthy and
thank you for being here absolutely
thank you michael it was a pleasure
thank you for inviting me
bye
thank you
[Music]
you